emergency powers were seen as the last
resort in Trump's wall crusade today the
power grab finally came
oddly casual in its tone I'm going to be
signing a national emergency and it's
been signed many times before it's been
signed by other presidents from 1977 or
so it gave the president's the power
we're talking about an invasion of our
country with drugs with human
traffickers with all types of criminals
and gangs this move gives the
president's the money he needs to
fulfill that campaign promise of a
border wall with Mexico the wall that
most Americans don't actually want this
move by passes Congress usurping one of
its primary functions the so-called
power of the purse President Trump is
looking to fund the walls construction
using money from a number of government
departments it includes 600 million
dollars from the Treasury's forfeiture
fund which is money taken from the
proceeds of criminal activity almost 1.4
billion dollars will come from the
Department for homeland security 2.5
billion can be drawn from the Department
of Defense's budget with a further 3.5
billion from that same departments
construction budget it might seem
straightforward but the fight isn't over
we will have a national emergency and we
will then be sued and they will sue us
in the ninth circuit even though it
shouldn't be there and we will possibly
get a bad ruling and then we'll get
another bad ruling and then we'll end up
in the Supreme Court and hopefully we'll
get a fair shake and we'll win in the
Supreme Court
so Trump seems resigned to the idea that
he's now entering a world of legal pain
the ultimate decision will likely rest
with the Supreme Court which because of
his appointments is now
conservative-leaning but what's clear
here is that this wall is not going to
be built overnight
we will build a great wall along the
southern border but Trump can at least
say he's doing everything within his
power to get the wall keeping his
supporters happy in time for the 2020
election even before the emergency
declaration was signed the Democrats
were on the warpath
the concept of using a national
emergency declaration to try and somehow
justify one more try at billions of
dollars in additional investments in
border security when a diligent thorough
several week long bipartisan process has
been followed and produced a positive
outcome
I'm strikes me as a simply terrible idea
the Democrats can bring a resolution to
block the use of emergency powers but
they need Republican support in the
Senate and Trump could ultimately veto
it anyway some Republicans are concerned
about the precedent this sets for the
next Democratic president to grab
emergency powers Trump's insistence of a
crisis at the border isn't shared by his
intelligence chiefs his statements about
widespread crime committed by
undocumented immigrants aren't backed by
statistics this is seen as a trump made
emergency which he's clinging to with
all his presidential might Amanda
Walker's Sky News Washington